BECAUSE NONE OF THE TRUMP
VICTORY IS COMING.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE PART TWO.
HERE TO RESPOND, HERMAN KANE,
2016 REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
FIRST BILL WELLS WHICH IS LIKE
BACK TO THE 90s, AND THEN JOE
WALSH.
HOW MANY MORE OF THE PRETENDERS
FOR THE MEDIA GLOM ONTO TO
PROMOTE?
>> THEY WILL GLOM ONTO ANYBODY
WHO IS WILLING TO CAST
ASPERSIONS ON DONALD TRUMP.
I WILL SUM UP THIS JOE WALSH,
NOT THE ONE FROM THE EAGLES, THE
ONE WHO WANTS TO CHALLENGE TRUMP
IN ONE WORD, PUBLICITY.
THE SQUAD, ALC, AND ALL OF THESE
OTHER LIBERALS, I'M SORRY,
LUNATICS.
THE MORE OUTRAGEOUS THINGS THAT
THEY SAY, THE MORE LIKELY THEY
ARE TO BE ON TV.
SO WHEN JOE WALSH COMES ALONG
AND IS GOING TO CHALLENGE TRUMP,
THE LIBERALS ARE GOING TO SAY,
WE HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE THAT WE
CAN PUT IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
IT'S FOR PUBLICITY, ITS OWN SELF
PUBLICITY BECAUSE HE HAS SEEN
THIS WORK.
THE MORE OUTRAGEOUS, THE MORE
LIKELY THEY ARE TO THE
PUBLICITY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE THE FIRST
PEOPLE TO SCREAM FOUL, OR GO
AFTER THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
THEY SAY THEY'RE GOING TO PUNCH
THE PRESIDENT IN THE FACE?
NO PROBLEM.
THERE YOU ARE GOING TO BURN IT
DOWN, KILL OFF ALL THE
SURVIVORS -- I'M BASICALLY
PARAPHRASING WHAT JENNIFER RUBIN
SAID.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
IF ANY OF THE ESSAY THAT, YOU
DON'T WORK AGAIN.
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BRING
DOWN 164 MILLION REPUBLICAN
VOTERS, YOU ARE SIMPLY NOT.
THAT MADE IT DELUSIONAL WHAT YOU
SHOWED EARLIER, ABSOLUTELY
DELUSIONAL.
SHE TALKS ABOUT PLAYING NICE.
WHILE REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO
PLAY NICE, THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE PLAYING NICE WITH THAT
KIND OF RHETORIC AND ALL THAT
RHETORIC DOES IS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY GET ON TV WHILE SOMEBODY
WRITES AN ARTICLE THAT QUOTES
THEM OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Laura: THEY GET A FANCY
PERCH HAD "NEW YORK TIMES" AND
THEY BECOME A HOUSE
CONSERVATIVE.
THERE'S NOTHING CONSERVATIVE
ABOUT THESE PEOPLE, THEY LONG
GAVE UP THEIR CONSERVATIVE
CREDENTIALS.
JOHN KASICH, HE DIDN'T EVEN SHOW
UP FOR THE NATIONAL CONVENTION.
HE WAS A GOVERNOR OF THIS STATE
WHEN IT WAS IN CLEVELAND.
HE'S NOW MOUTHING OFF ABOUT HOW
HE WAS THE FIRST ONE TO REALLY
DOUBT TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> I CALL HIM OUT MORE THAN
ANYBODY AND HAVE BEEN DOING IT.
I DIDN'T HAVE LIKE A CHANGE OF
HEART BUT WE SEE SOME PEOPLE WHO
SAY, I USED TO SUPPORT HIM, AND
NOW I DON'T.
I SUSPECTED THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING, THAT THIS WOULD BE
DISRUPTIVE TO OUR COUNTRY AND
DISRUPTIVE TO OUR ALLIES AND
IT'S BEEN PRECISELY THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY I TOLD YOU
SO.
>> Laura: BUT HERMAN -- >>
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
CAN WE SAY, SOUR GRAPES?